mon premier qui l'a dit pop up ou c'est
qu'il est il est là vous me voyez est ce
que vous me voyez sur un site de
rencontres franchement
les inquiète à sur un site de rencontres
a déjà été ou qui allaient ils m'ont
donné un abonnement à vie car premium
c'est la carte vermeil
qui a dit ça c'est une énorme star
chanteurs acteurs et d r je vous dirais
je vis c'est moi pour parler de moi mais
on ne parle jamais de la solitude des
stars bien c'est hallucinant checkez
sophistes et se faire dûment sophie
marceau à propos de son célibat el hadi
pour célibataires sophie marceau si mme
banon est passé à bercy mais on nous
annonce officiellement et salut la terre
elle donne tout un tas d interview dans
laquelle elle met pas ces libelles à ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta
hugo n'a jamais autant parlé depuis qui
n'a pas les caisses gallagher la
prochaine mais c'est parce que tu toi tu
devrais savoir mais toi toi depuis xe le
tout avec un wii break 7 et mac adam
d'air mais non à lui son tramway puis si
ce 4200 son copain parce qu'elle a
déclaré okah semaine dernière histoire
les terminer hilmar cet homme d'affaires
il a alors quoi mais arrêter n'importe
quoi il pas mort du tout alors c'est
très bizarre cette émission les
sénateurs lui dit qu'il est en couple et
lui dit qu'ils les mangent bien manger
parce que les infos sont comme nous
vraiment j'ai récupéré sa place donc
est-ce que mathieu juste je suis obligée
de réagir parce qu'un de nos concurrents
a fait la une récemment en disant que
cette histoire était terminée et dans
les interviews que donne cette semaine
sophie marceau elle explique que bah oui
elle est célibataire et qu'elle
donnerait elle n'irait pas sur un site
de rencontre et puis finalement elle a
ouvert la porte et là elle a évoqué
l'hypothèse d'un pseudo voilà alors
est-ce qu'on a un extrait du berceau au
passage je sais pas non là dix ans non
alors elle allait dit si je n'ai pas été
ce film marceau est ce que je serai sur
un site de rencontre a priori ce n'est
pas le truc qui m'emballe après il est
possible de trouver l'amour sur les
réseaux cela dépend de ce qu'on y
recherche il y a des gens même très
convoité et vous savez conditionnelle
oui mais vous savez qu'il ya un site
pour pour star il s'est élancé qui
s'appellera ya absolument il fallait
donc donner sur facebook coin combien on
gagne ce qu'on fait ce qu'on ait connu
et puis ensuite on est on est on est on
est accepté ou pas est coopté par des
gens connus voilà j'avais été acceptée
guillaume frisquet que j'adore c'est la
même demande il a été refusé
et mois que j'y suis allé j'ai vu des
gens connus je dirai pas qui qui va dire
si vous insistez
mathieu à les battre
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un que j'adore libéraux star
de balmain qui est devenu un ami
d'ailleurs
c'est pas vraiment quand même connu
aussi oliveros teintera connue a fait
l'objet de la star de balmain si
j'allais bien connu mais bon on a pas si
vous tournez avec jean mis en boîte de
nuit on s'est marré je crois aussi mais
je crois qu'il l'a dit l'un mais gad
elmaleh dessus gad elmaleh et dessus
aussi alors il ya aussi ben affleck à
matthew perry à kara délai bein ja oui
et puis jean michel qui sont en effet
bannir paraît-il c'est vrai la demande
sinon c'est un pote qui m'avait copté
kim et inscriptions maison tu a raillé
défi qu'a donc dit ah non c'est pas
obligé palais cheval fait qu'annoncer
pas son truc et sinon il ya bouder aussi
nantais quote
moi j'y suis allée puis je vous avais
dit le problème c'est qu'en fait en
france une à 4,5 et sinon tout le reste
tu rencontres un mec super beau et unité
août et acteur il y avait des je dirai
pas qui mais vraiment les acteurs connus
mais sur l'australie en angleterre là
j'ai pas faire durer quinze mille bombes
pour tirer un coup à ses dépens qu'il
bouche où on voit si c'est pour arriver
la moumoute d'elton john non t'es gentil
ça va mieux
[Applaudissements]